kleinster software wird über aggression
machen mussten ja hallo ich heiße mal
leica und das ist meine familie
die affen mensch du dachpappe das stück
scheiße habe ich so nie von gehört wie
affe ganz oft affe da sind sachen dabei
die jeden so tief in der haut dass ich
die gar nicht mit water jetzt
wiederholen möchte du schwarzes
miststück gehörst umgebracht ich bin
annabelle mandeng ich bin schauspielerin
moderatorin und synchronsprecherin und
für mich bedeutet schwarz seien in
deutschland mich rechtfertigen zu müssen
dass ich teil der deutschen bevölkerung
bin warum haben sie mir ist alles nicht
gleich erzählt mir wurden im laufe
meiner karriere sehr oft rollen
angeboten die noten waren flüchtlinge
oder putzfrauen die habe ich abgelehnt
ich habe gesagt ich möchte keine
klischees spielen
ich habe als schauspielerin mit einem
ganz klaren ablehnung auf meiner
hautfarbe zum teil zu tun in dem mir zum
beispiel auch mal gesagt wurde
hauptrollen werden nur weiß besetzt
hallo mein name ist tyron ricketts ich
bin 46 jahre alt ich habe einen
deutschen pass ich bin in österreich zur
welt gekommen und lebe hier seit ich
sechs jahre alt bin
im deutschen film bin ich zu 80 prozent
der amerikaner
ich bin der engländer ich bin der gerade
geflüchtete der aus afrika kommt und das
sind nicht immer schlechte rollen sind
teilweise gut und interessante rollen
wichtig ist dass man durch diese art der
rollen für die für die breite mehrheit
eben im außen verortet wird man wird
nicht erzählt als jemand der teil dieser
gesellschaft sein kann sondern man ist
immer der andere und das unterstreicht
natürlich diesen wir ihr blickwinkel und
das menschenleben nicht blond und
blauäugig sind nicht in deutschland zu
suchen haben
das ist ein problem also für mich ist
also großes problem zum beispiel die
beiden lieben den lieben dich sehr und
ich merke einfach dass bei der kleinen
mit drei jahren schon gewisse ich würde
ich sagen identitäts kriegt das wäre
vielleicht ein bisschen qualm aber
fragen aufkommen einfach ne warum die
charaktere die sie am meisten mag warum
die ihre farbe haben sondern also das
glas möglich eine dreijährige und das
sagt sie auch so das ist richtig sagt
sie dann aber auch dass sie anders sein
aussehen will wie sie aussieht weil die
die sag ich mal ein bisschen zu denen
sie hoch schaut weil die anders aussehen
sie möchte auch so aussehen sondern und
das sind einfach situationen wo man sich
einfach wünscht dass das einfach
diversität in allen bereichen einfach
offen gemacht wird das ist kein versteck
des rassismus das offenen rassismus jahr
machen wir uns nichts vor es ist doch
nicht versteckt wenn man direkt betitelt
na ja wir können die zuschauer können
sich wahrscheinlich nicht mit ihnen
identifizieren ich natürlich können sie
sich mit uns identifizieren
schließlich sind wir die bevölkerung
hier sind 25 jeder vierte deutsche ist
ein mensch mit migrationshintergrund ist
man das muss man sich vor augen führen
sind 25 prozent der deutschen
bevölkerung bis zu 30 prozent in diesem
jahr wahrscheinlich und dann zu meinen
dass sich der zuschauer nicht mit uns
identifizieren kann das sind alte
strukturen das sind festgefahrene
krusten die müssen aufgebrochen werden
mein name ist immerhin das neue spieler
[Musik]
so klar war cottbus schon cottbus schon
vermischen harte zeit war ich so einen
hass noch nie erlebt habe wenn du mit
bananen beschmissen wirst und auch das
gefühl hast du stehst da alleine und ich
wurde einmal gefragt hast du mal mit
jemandem aber gesprochen weil ich meinen
eltern nicht damit belasten wollte und
hat wieder geschafft dass allein das ist
ja das problem dass viele leute es mein
und denken es ist es ist ja es gibt
keinen rassismus in deutschland und wenn
du davon berichtet und davon echt
übertreibt wir übertreiben nicht ich
könnte tausende geschichten erzählen
aber wenn du anfängst dass dort sehr
sagt ach so dass weg ist so ja es ist
weg gesucht
wenn deshalb kanada eine wohnungs oder
so sobald man ein nachname sieht ist das
schon ein problem also meistens wenn ich
anrufe dann ist es soweit ich das so gut
deutsch sprechen dann wissen sie nicht
dass ich eigentlich also denken sie dass
die leute die mit afrikaner verheiratet
ist dann komme ich da hinten die sind
schon einmal so schockierend anmerkt und
ist wieder ganz andere stimmung dann ist
es nicht mehr so nett und freundlich und
den finde ich auch da muss auch um die
was passieren also das geht auch nicht
der monster mit der auf einmal englisch
und eine andere verbringen die deutschen
ihren sprecher immer englisch mal haben
wir schon vorher mit einem solchen foren
und einfach und rechtsfragen wie an
englisch zu sprechen
ja und zwar weil das so tauchen spieler
irgendwann hab' mir meine tochter gesagt
so ja sie hat gesagt sie wolle nicht mit
nicht spielen weil ich schwarz bin und
also und sagen schwarz ist hässlich das
war so bis diese schwarzes hässlich du
bist dreckig und wolle nicht mit dir
spielen und ich war so war man weiß ja
nicht wie man was am ende darf situation
wieder gehen sonst und aber als ich zu
hause habe ich dann gesagt nein ein
kritischer zu den eltern gehen sollen
sie sagen müssen ihr könnt ihr bitte
euer kind mag vielleicht auch mal so
bescheid sagen dass es nicht richtig ist
dass fähigkeiten
die eltern sehen das und die samen
machen nichts dagegen und die kinder
sagen dann weiter also sie sind dann
findest ganz normalen unsere dreijährige
hat seitdem wir nach charlottenburg
gezogen sind öfter mal gemerkt dass sie
in der bahn einfach angeguckt wird und
das sagt sie nein gesagt aber warum
gucken mich die leute hier so komisch an
dann kommt auch so eine frage so was ist
denn mit mir also sohn also das ist
gerade immer drei und fängt schon an an
sich zu zweifeln
und das ist auch das ist traurig dass
man bei einem dreijährigen kind schon so
stark gegensteuern minuten und dem
einfach nur sagen dann erklären muss
dass sie normal ist das alles mit ihr
okay ist mein name ist hase ich bin
sprecher der initiative schwarze
menschen in deutschland und aus meiner
sicht hat deutschland ein tief sitzendes
rassismus problem in allen
gesellschaftlichen strukturen und ebenen
[Musik]
als ich das video zum ersten mal gesehen
hat dachte ich echt gepasst ich nur an
den clip war vor allem glaube ich für
mich rassistisch dass sie eine weiße
hand eine schwarze person durch den
durch den raum schnitts dieses schnipsen
in dieses café dieses kleine kolonie
kaffee also auch da nur so ein hinweis
sozusagen auch die koloniale
vergangenheit und vor allen dingen dann
da habe ich wirklich gedacht das kann
einfach nicht sein diese buchstaben
wieder eingeblendet werden nacheinander
und volumen für eine kurze sequenz eben
das android erkennbar wird wo ich mir
dachte dass das in der kombination mit
all den anderen punkten oder so kann
kein zufall sein
da hat sich entweder irgendwie überhaupt
keinen kopf gemacht oder ist steckt den
intentionen hinter die emsstraße
beispielsweise die eindeutig
rassistischen begriff beinhaltet oder
eben spaß nahm eine kommunale verbrecher
geehrt werden da stellt sich die frage
wollen wir uns wirklich auf diese
menschen beziehen wollen wir wirklich
sozusagen solche begriffe zum wert der
kann und sehen lassen und das im
öffentlichen raum stattfinden lassen
also wir plädieren ganz stark dafür die
emsstraße umzubenennen ok meine mutter
stammt aus berlin mein vater aus dem
sudan
ich wurde im alter in etwa von acht
jahren umbenannt ich hatte zuvor einen
ja arabisch sudanesischen namen meine
mutter war damals der meinung es sei
besser einen deutschen namen in
deutschland zu tragen damit man auch in
deutschland erfolg haben könne
mein name ist di luca blitz und ich bin
pressesprecher der polizei berlin
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass diese
zahlen tatsächlich allumfassend die
taten aufzeigen die deutschlandweit
passieren es ist wichtig dass wir diese
straftaten zur kenntnis bekommen
deshalb ist es wichtig dass man
rassistische beleidigungen rassistische
gewalt an zeigt damit wie sie verfolgen
können ich bin viel in bari ich leite
die anti diskriminierungs
beratungsstelle e-tron bei youtube und
wir beraten schwarze afrikanische und
afro diaspora menschen in allen fällen
von diskriminierung ja es gibt menschen
die kommen zu uns und sie sagen ja ich
wurde einfach nur kontrolliert weil ich
schwarz bin ich saß im park ich habe
nichts gemacht ist das ein andere leute
da und die polizisten sind direkt zu mir
gekommen
ausgrenzung diskriminierung und
rassismus zersetzen die gesamte
gesellschaft und ja es gibt auch fälle
in der polizei berlin wenn sie das
gefühl haben dass die kontrolle aus
rassistischer motivation ergangen ist
oder dass man sie ja wohl auf
rassistischer grundlage beleidigt hat
dann bringen sie das zur anzeige es ist
wichtig dass wir damit arbeiten können
ja also wir wünschen uns natürlich dass
es da einfach mehr kontrolle gibt ein
ganz wichtige forderung die wir haben
ist eine unabhängige beschwerdestelle
die außerhalb der polizei steht und da
braucht die staatsanwaltschaft einfach
nochmal ein separates gremium eine
separate stelle die diese ermittlungen
führt ich bin der karamba diaby bin und
dass abgeordnete der spd aus dem
wahlkreis halle an der saale
ich lebe in halle seit 35 jahren und
habe die stadt nie länger als vier
wochen verlassen
am anfang des jahres sind
einschusslöcher fünf löcher auf den
scheiben hierbei auf mein büro gefunden
worden
und ich war sehr traurig weil der ort
hier meinen wahlkreis wieder ist eine
otte dialogs als zentraler ort in halle
das ist barrierefrei jeder mensch ist
eingeladen jeder kann zu mir kommen
seine anliegen vortragen mit mir ins
gespräch kommen
als das passiert war war ich traurig
ich stelle fest dass in den letzten drei
jahren in den bundestag daher reden
gehalten von abgeordnete aber nicht nur
dort sondern auch in den landtagen
diese reden sind voller hass voller
beleidigungen erniedrigung und
insbesondere über minderheiten in diesem
land ich denke jeder politikerin jeder
politiker der solche rede hält muss sich
gedanken machen wie er oder sie negative
dazu beiträgt dass die spaltung in der
gesellschaft hier stattfindet und wir
brauchen keine spaltung wir brauchen
zusammenhalt in dieser gesellschaft
[Musik]